Music
Okay, so this week we are getting the horses to be attentive to our immediate aids.
So we're putting them through some drills.
So as part of our groundwork, we are just going to get the horses to be very prompt about coming forward with our step and stopping with our step.
So you see here the result of this young horse.
We have a four year old warm blood here and he's mostly distracted.
And so this is a great exercise for him to do to become attentive to the handler and eventually the rider.
So essentially the exercise is you're just going to walk some very consistent steps and then you're going to obviously halt and correct the horse.
They want you want to make sure the horse is standing directly beside you in line with you and their ears are on you and they stop when you stop your legs.
So at first you are going to go through with your voice commands by saying whoa and clucking or saying walk on depending on what your horse is used to.
And then after a while you want to be able to get to a point where the horse is so attentive that they're just watching you the whole time.
To make the corrections, you want to just replace the horse to the exact position to the millimeter where you wanted them to stop in the end.
OK, so that's very important that you're consistent and systematic about the way that you correct them.
And we're going to do this on both sides at the walk and the trot.
So eventually when your horse is really good in the walk, then you can move to the trot and change your hands so that you're on both sides of them.
If we want to ride them on both sides, we must work them on the ground on both sides.
If we want them to be even on both sides, you must work them on both sides.
Good. Make sure that you're praising them a lot every time that they are right and not correcting them and withholding praise when they're not right so that they know the clear difference.
And then when they're standing still, then you can pet them and praise them again with your voice and with your pets.
Another correction we want to make sure is present is you don't want them hanging on the line on the rope.
So they should be on a loose rope, paying attention the whole time.
So whenever you need to use the rope or the whip, in this case, I'm carrying a whip.
You might not always need a whip if your horse is more sensitive.
This horse is not sensitive and could use the correction of the whip.
So whenever you're using the rope, then make sure that you're letting it go so that it can re-neutralize onto a loose rein and the horse is truly following you and looking at what you're actually doing.
So here we have the correction of the trot. So where he started, where he was confused, he was distracted.
So start with a little jog, correct them, go back to the walk for a few steps, make sure that they understand the exercise from the walk again, and then re-invite the trot so that they can understand.
You can see me there really accentuating the halt so that he's extra aware that it's going to happen and he can follow really well.